Hello各位晚安
今天是9月15号早上
不是早上
晚上的8点
大概45分
正式课程大概15分钟后才会开始
那旁边有同学说他想要做空
这里
MNQ算是做空方的标准图
那我们来聊一下
我今天其实一整天都没有办法去
好好的静下来下单
那我们先来聊一下今天的这个
现在的这个位置
为什么我会说同学现在看的这个小那
我会说不要去在这个地方做空
你知道吗
来我们现在
大家应该都看得出来
上面有个压力对不对
对
但是你有没有看到下面一件事情
甚至同学在讲的时候
我记得是在这个附近
就在这一根正在行程的时候
来请问
我放大一点给大家看
请问一下
在同学观察要做空的这个边界以前
请问市场是长出上以线
还是下面的下一件
到底是哪一个
应该蛮明显的吧
所以市场是跌下来
然后就有人抖抖抖抖买上去
这是不对的
我说对做空来讲
代表你的对面做多的军队很强
他们有很大的大魔王在你眼前
所以我们应该是先后退一步闪一下
那什么时候在这张图会变成是
是你适合做的
我目前还不知道
但是我目前看到的是这个
惯性都还在
你看
有没有
所以我不觉得这是一个好的做空点
那什么时候可以呢
我们来假装一下
假设
现在突然间又来一个这样子
我们来玩接接乐
这根突然间这样子
稍微大根一点
好,跌破这个边界
然后跌破以后
假设从这边
这样跌破以后
又从这边由下往上回来到你刚刚在观察的这条线的时候
哎
那個就不一樣了因為他的樓梯已經本來的漲多跌的涨多跌少在这个的过程中变成跌多跌多以后有可能继续涨多
那我们就等 等它变跌多以后的涨少
那在这个地方出现尖尖的上不去 上不去
在这种地方空 画歪了
在这种地方空相对会比你眼前的这个来的漂亮多了
或是这个平面被一个很明显的上引线的单子
这个不叫明显
这个类似像这样子
剧烈的撞上去
可能撞了20点上去
但是同一根5分K
瞬间咻的缩回来
你在这个的后面一根在这里做测试
一样是这个边界
那这样子我觉得还OK
但是不能是在
在上面平平的底下斜斜的都还没有破
也还没有惯性烂掉这样子往下烂掉的过程中
就去做这件事
这样好不好
哇Bruce很厉害耶
又通关一个账号
我的妈呀我觉得同学其实都很强
然后再来
从大科度的角度来看
我不知道大家有沒有在今天看過日線
來
大家有沒有看我FB發文
我說今天的這個日線的邊界
其實是一個很棒的這種日線邊界
為什麼呢
哎
這種日線來前一天
在這個地方邊界尖尖的下引線
這種地方
哦
那你說呢
所以
以長線來看
这边要做空
你会很容易遇到更大刻度的大魔王
我不敢说你一定会失败
只是我眼前看到的就是
连日线都呈现各种下不去的样子
甚至连那个谁
那个MU
记忆体最近不是叠很凶吗
像美光这种
你去看他的日线
日线才漂亮好不好
日線
我的MV我是買在那個
我的公司帳號那邊
我不是買在這這樣來你看看日線昨天盤中好凶但是在這種邊界居然出現這樣子的日線這一根日線的暗示
他做多的那個暗示遠遠超過前面的好幾根
這樣
ok
然後我也有趁機去在底下去建倉
然後今天我在中間還有加碼
但是我的加碼我是下午
很隨意的看到我就加了一下
你說後面又跌下來對不對
对但是我这里就加一口
我当时在这附近我吃了四口
所以加了一口
然后中间现在均加在这个地方
所以目前就是五口在这
那我中间这边有没有可能差一点被打掉
有啊
说不定大家今天晚上如果他没有上去
我现在打开给大家看到的就是被打掉的
这样子而已
OK
好
那
有关于长线的角度
大家知道吧
那我现在我还没有打算
把我的部位NQ从五口再继续放大
我目前就先这样子
为什么呢
因为今天才礼拜二
结算是这个礼拜五
所以还有好几天要震荡
我也不知道它会发生什么事
所以我认为
这几天就先这样子
我现在这边建立五口的基本部位
如果有机会让我报过结算
甚至是结算后
那让我有机会继续留着
然后还在慢慢建仓的话
结算后我会更愿意去增加我的部位
所以目前就先这样子
而且他距离我的均价
以日线来看都还没有远离我的日线
所以就先这样子吧
OK
然后来看一下同学在问的一些股票等等
讲到玉山
眼前看到玉山我先讲一下
好了我最近叫我们家女儿
我在教她做交易
我相信有一些同学应该有听到
那我就指挥她
我想说借着这样子的方式
她用她自己的户头
然后指挥她说
哪些地方可以买可以卖怎么样
然后我就叫她最近把玉山金
她卖在46块
这是女儿的账号
你看那个股数都是零股而已
她都还没有
因为它的里面的存款其实也不多
反正就是先给他几万块钱
那些都是他的历年来的压税钱全部存起来这样慢慢的玩然后我要他去在玉山基46的时候卖他卖在就是46就挂卖
然后台达店我要他在这附近去买
所以就是想说就借由这个机会
这样子我看台达店
那他买的位置大概就是
就是这个边界这附近这样
好不好
那这个想法其实不会到太难
因为这边就是下不去的样子
今天团中长上去
后面又说一些回来
无所谓就丢着
这样子
所以这个是我女儿的部位
我自己其实也约绿在附近
就开始在吃我的部位
好
那
我们去看一下
同学们
通常你这个文字比较多一点
我可能会先截起来
让我慢慢的看
小娜停顺
好我们看一下这个好了
等我一下
我找一下小娜在哪里
小娜的5K
来来来
刚刚我是不是说斜斜的这样子
我是不是跟那位同学说不要做空
有没有
对吧
包含现在也不要做空
你现在涨多跌少,涨多跌少
现在还在涨多当中
不要开玩笑
这样好不好
那8点11
8点11好,早上吗
早上
8点11,应该在这附近对不对
在这边好
然后所以你会买在这边
先被点掉,可以啊
你这个出手我就ok啊
这个OK
我如果看到我应该会先赔一次
然后没有赚到这个
会啊
我可能也会想要赌赌看
赌这个尖尖的看
它会不会是真的
赌失败就失败
它就只是众多失败中的其中一个
这样子
这个赌我觉得还OK
因为够贫
然后这个尖尖的
然后又是早上的八点这种
就是亚洲市场刚要醒来的样子
好可以
我觉得那没有什么问题
不用修正什么停损就被点掉而已
就这样子
然后这边有一位Larry同学
我看一下
我们这个交易法小10k搭配5分k
如果60分k一直往右上角走
在比较高的位置盘整
可以在小10k的地方
区间下远找5分k的图进场吗
当然可以
你都已经是在
你都已经说你是5分k
注意听
5分k配上60k
60k
你都已经是这样子搭配了
那對60K的對5分K來說
只要這大顆度的下源
基本上你就是幹嘛
就在這邊找東西做啊
OK啊沒有什麼問題
沒有問題的好不好
所以等著小10K高位盤整完就上去了
我覺得我們就用現在的小10K來看好了
现在的小10k你其实找不太到什么盘整的感觉
你现在小10k大概就是看到上面的边界在这
下面的边界其实在这边
底下这个边界这对日线来讲
其实也是一个很漂亮的这种
市场互换的边界
3545敦泰周K是重要的边界打击区吗
我们来看一下3545敦泰你说周K吗
重要的打击区没错
但是我相信同学们应该知道
一看到我在讲的话大家就知道
前一周很凶
本周
目前是涨上去又掉下来
所以日线变成这样子
对吧
你心里要有底
在这个宽度48上下
可能到47多
这附近会这样子来回的震荡
来回的震荡
你心中要有个底
它不会是很明确的
因为出现这样子的东西
出现这个
理论上这整理的这几天后面应该要就直接这样上去才对
这才符合那个该发生的样子
但是他没有所以又回来又回来这边弱弱的样子那这边是不是容易有人买的确但是目前买的人还不够利如果你真的要吃
请你用非常小的部位去测
测这个边界
然后在这边可能要抓一个稍微宽一点点的区间
像这样子的方式
然后去捕捉那个边界
这样子
好不好
用相对小的资本去做大科度
是的
我其实很推荐这样子
我前几天我才在那个会员频道里面讲说
说你其实是可以直接做一个纯60k的交易
那例如说
我就用眼前的小娜来当举例就好了
等一下我这个拉到旁边
好大一个
例如说眼前的小娜纯60k
你知道纯60k哦
你会在
这根k棒长这样子的时候
你会在这个地方吃60k的单子
然后你的防守就是这里
所以我这样目测
一个60分k的防守就是50点
50 60点或70点我不知道就目测
那我们就抓多一点
抓70点好了
所以你就评估啦
如果我下10口的围形
70点1400美金会痛好
但是我又想要做长刻度的
做长线单子
那我就不要下10口啊
一口单会承受140美金
你就扪心自问
我如果连续亏10次
我都还承受得住的那个额度是多少
假设就140美金
连续亏10次我还承受得住好
那我就不要下10口
我就下1口
然后你所承受的风险就是140美金
然后做长线
长线的不会意思是上去再回来
再慢慢的加你的第二口
上去再回来再慢慢加三或加四
再把那个后面第几口第几口
这样在后面加上去
那这就会是直接变成是一个60分K等级
然后又符合我们的交易的单子
这样好不好
你自己要去评估
因为每个人他所能够承受的这个
金钱科度的多寡不太一样但是我很推荐大科度OKBruce同学说一定要吃在原地田顿后面
对对对
Bruce同学这个原地田顿
刚好跟今天的课程的主题
有很大的关系
OK
新手看60K大边界
我觉得各位
请把
这种资深同学他们给出来的经验
拿来内化一下
你看
就是小科度第一次到边界别吃
第二次回来
直接喷走就跟他说拜拜
这样子
有没有
很多人舍不得那个直接喷走说拜拜的这件事情
所以他会在底下密集的测试
测一次测两次测十次都还不停手
因为他舍不得自己喷出没赚到
对
你越舍不得
你反而越赚不到
反而是我们这些比较舍得的
很轻松
没有就算了
随意吃的
反而是这样子做交易的人
都会默默的不小心
就过了
对啊
好不好
大科度也适合用CFD做吗
第一个
我没有做CFD
小纳5分K不能在这里空
不行
这个边界是由上往下踩
要做空5分K的人
你要等他由下往上撞到这里
是这样子才有空间
不是现在
拜托
好不好
现在这样子还很硬
虽然你说他会不会下来
有目前看起来力量往下
但是不要这么做
我们来回答一下那个CFD
第一个我没有做CFD
所以CFD通常都是开在外汇的券商里面
或是开在虚拟货币的券商里
简单的说它不是正规的股票
它是用衍生性商品的概念
去合成出类似股票的合约
让你持有那些标的物
我大致上讲是这样
你自己Google搜寻或问AI
什么叫做CFD
那通常他都是带着杠杆
也就是跟期货一样
例如说100块你准备100块你可以买500块的股票就是带着那个杠杆那我通常我不会做太多杠杆的事
因为本身期货已经带着杠杆
那你在IB里面
其实你IB本身
你是可以开杠杆用的
例如说你丢10万美金
你可能会有20万美金的buying power
那个购买力
但是你不用全部用掉
多用的那些
其实券上会跟你算利息
那你就自己要拿捏
我没有说利息划算或不划算
如果你只是用一倍而已
我觉得这样还好
你自己去拿捏
但是我不建议的是常态性大量的开这种
其实如果行情一直在那边盘整
或是你是亏损状态
你还用利息借来的钱
然后去吃一个呈现亏损状态的部位
我那个是亏上加亏
这样会两个都是负的
這樣好不好
3037這幾天是不是都在打擊區
好 我們看一下
我們等一下再看個幾支
然後我們就
就來
來等一下
都在打擊區
我不建議去規劃3037的打擊區
你知道為什麼嗎
我們就用日跟週好了
因為這位同學沒有給我週期
所以我就自己规划说
假设我要做日线单
那我的大刻度就是周线
所以我就先到周线看一下
周线第一秒钟
我看到的是这个边界
曾经有个跳空缺口
这里有一堆上影线
上不去
有缺口在这里
过去的两周
一周两周
这个1000块
包含这边
好像变成一个
一个心理上面上不去的一点
这样子
然后我在判断第二件事情
叫做成交量
有没有大量的人困在上面
我们看嘛
很多成交量的这边对下来
对不起
很高价的这边对下来
有没有人困在上面
其实有耶
这里呢
成交量也是有出来的耶
所以我光这样想我就知道
哇
這個邊界是有一堆人困在這邊
好 那我就知道這周線不好做
來到日線
日線
我知道你在看這個
我知道
你再看这个东西
破底翻
你知道这种破底翻
它涨的位置
来
它涨的位置涨在
我们刚刚看到周线
周线是不是上面有这里的压力
这是周线看到的
甚至这边有支撑
变成好几天的压力
对不对
这个破底翻
它是涨在这个大颗度的哪里
哇
好像涨在一个不是很明确的地方
你说老鱼你为什么不画这边
好啦就算我画这里
就算我画这里
哇
它也不是长在这啊
它是长在
这个
你知道我讲的吧
就是
所以基本上我看到像这样子的股票
我会一秒钟
直接略过
拜拜
因为它的周线不漂亮
那为什么我刚刚会叫
会说我自己在吃
然后我也叫我女儿吃那个
台达电
同样的周线
它的周线是在下缘
容易产生这边
我前一次吃在这附近上去回来
在我的军教被我处理掉了
所以我没有真的是亏到什么东西
然后但是底下这里
来注意看
它在上缘下缘
它是不是相对偏哪里
偏下缘
有没有
包含周线也是偏下缘
所以我就会开始去观察
1600这附近市场在干嘛
那天一开盘直接往下跌
跌到1560这边
居然有人买上去
我其实心里就知道
有人在买
就这样子
好不好
刚刚说要做空的
有没有
我阻止了你
你看现在这边不是很好空
这个涨多跌少的力量都还在
但是这边不代表说你要做多
这边的这个做多也没有到很漂亮
好吗
那我先暂时回来讲今天的主题
反正我今天会有很多时间带着大家这样子看盘
我们先随意的看一下黄金
因为等一下会有一个地方来讲黄金
刚刚黄金有人讲吗
黄金5分K可以等互换吗
你说这里吗
我退一步看一下
我在这边先标一下黄金的5分K的线
然後呢我退一步到60K看一下大家看一下我的動作我标一下我的线我退一步到60k看我直接打退堂鼓
这个60k好尴尬
我找不到
我找不到那种明确的边界
如果哪一天这个60k是这样子
例如说
是这样子
又涨上去
涨上去又回来到这个地方同样这条线
你在这个时候跟我说我想要观察5分k
那我会跟你说可以值得观察
但是现在我一看完这个我就收起5分k想要在这个捕捉互换的这个想法
完全就放掉了
而且来特别讲一下
这个地方的下影线
他应该在隔壁这边撑住该发生
他应该就要上去
因为这个影线这么长
市场有这个成交量这么用力
所以现在就是这么用力做多的这些人
一个一个失望
他失望停损
他也是
大家都停损
那成交量呢
有像这边这么大吗
还没有
所以代表大家还有很多人在凹
所以不要
不要不要
这个不好做
直接放掉
好
刚刚这个过程
请大家要练习一下
我每一次打开一张图
我的第一个动作
不是先直接下单
No
也不是先看图
第一个动作
永远往大一个刻度
先看一下
我看到日线的股票
我就去看周线的样子
我看到5分K的小娜
我就跑去看60分K大格局的样子
然后心理计划一下大格局的上中下
我每一次做我已经养成这个习惯了
我会做这件事
所以我就会知道说
眼前的这个交易机会的好跟坏
这样好不好
最后再看这两只股票
我们就先来聊一下今天的东西
3265跟
我們看一下
326日線波地翻
看一下台新科
我們看一下日線日線的波地翻我先看周線周線 我周線有點兇我知道這個邊界也在這裡 周線有點兇所以不見得很好吃
坦白講成交量的確蠻少的
因為光看K棒就知道
我跟各位講一下
成交量少的股票K棒會有個特色
就是他容易出現那種一根一根一根
十字線越來越多的這種K棒
通常成交量比較大的K棒
實體K棒有時薪的地方會比較多
我們看他周線
我沒有很愛
我沒有到很愛
又是因為他的回來的這個樣子
所以我會建議你
這附近這個邊界先不要亂摸
因為他回來的樣子有點凶
好不好
看起來其實要破要破的樣子
對啊
重新的等待好了
24742337週k日k是好的打擊區嗎
我們看一下
先看2474
可乘
你說
可乘的週k日k是打擊區嗎
根據我們昨天
剛剛所聊過的週線
我們看一下這個週線
一秒钟我的周线的定义会是
完全不考虑周线
日线呢
日线也不考虑
完全放掉
不知道他在干嘛
要喷就给他喷
拜拜
我宁愿不赚
反而是前一段时间
在8月的前面这边
来你看一下
如果在这个边界
如果我们是这一天的直播
你觉得
你跟我说老鱼老鱼
周线日线是好的打击区吗
如果是这样子
我是不是会开当时的周线
那个周线就会是在
就会是在这里
那天就会是长这样子
假设就这周
下一周还没出现
我会跟你说
周线上缘下缘
不错的周线下缘
我会这样
对吗
如果你是在这一周跟我讲这个
那我就会跟你说
那是不错
可以规划一下
183 185 180这附近随意吃的
差不多了
周线这样子
然后接下来就到日线去看嘛有没有那现在这个地方我才不管他周線或日線怎麼樣反正我看不懂我也覺得他好像偏高
有種噴你就噴吧
如果你底下有部位你就抱著啊
看他怎麼震盪會不會噴啊
這張單有一個地方
如果變成那樣子我會很開心
來
如果他哪一天出現一個下沙
我們來組合一下
如果出现这样子下沙到这里
然后再隔一天出现出现出现出现出现
像这样子的可以棒
出现在这里
注意看哦
整理整理的出一个小平台下沙
下沙以后出现哎呦这样子的周线
反而我会跟你说
这一周开始下一周开始
这附近是值得观察的点
那问可诚的这位
也是姓于的同学
你听得懂我在讲的
对不对
如果有出现那样子
我反而会说
你观察的不错
因为有周线的边界
还有跌破的尖尖的
那隔壁可以好好地观察
这样子OKOK
因为他打出了好的边界来
但是现在是一个
我不知道他在干嘛的地方
问号
最后看一下2337
然后我们就来聊一下今天的东西
来你刚刚说日线周线是不是好的打击虚
完全都不是
来第一个我们看一下长刻度的周线
周线边界我知道边界在这边
但是你有没有看到在周线的领域里面
它也是上面掉下来底下平平的
甚至前一周来看一下前一周
我们把这一周遮住
这周不要看
礼拜一礼拜二不要看
我们看假设现在回到周末
这是前一周的周线长这样子
你是不是心里就有个底
这是下沙的K棒
在我的萤幕红色是下沙的
那这样子的K棒代表
空方的力道有这么强大
做多的力道只有底下
一点点的这个小下影线而已
隔壁这一周继续跌的几率蛮高的
不是百分之百 但是就是蠻高的
如果像這樣子我就知道這個邊界
不用特別的急躁 我可以等它破
看它破以後長什麼樣子
再说
好不好
所以说周线算不算两条线的中间
这个地方我就不喜欢他嘛
所以其实我说不定可以等待这个地方
我现在还不知道
所以这周算是关键哦
为什么
因为这周如果收成这样子的下影线
代表他有能力跌破四周五周的边界
却又收回来
那反而隔壁又变成是好东西
知道这个差异吗
如果这一周是跌下去收回来的这一周
但是如果这一周是像这样子
像这样子
就这样子
假设这一周长这样收了
我们现在是周末礼拜六礼拜天
你看到这样子的图
你就知道这边来碰的几率就很高了
这样OK
好那我们先回来讲今天的这个主题一下
OK
然后同学有问到的这些
我在这边先圈起来
我先丢到旁边
我丢到旁边我记录起来
然后这样子我们等一下就可以
我就可以来聊
我先从这边聊
好不好
那今天来聊的主题是
第一个
宝宇你怎么知道股市会上涨
我说我们用集市盘来揭露
对不对
那既然这样子
我们先暂时回来看一下
眼前的小娜的样子
这个上不去下不去我没有很爱哦
哎哟小娜有微微的惯性烂掉
但是这个烂掉有点尴尬
你说老鱼做空你守这边可不可以
如果你是做空在这附近守这边
有啦很短但是就是勉强接受至少至少要这样
但是这不是我认知的惯性跌破
因为事实上他没有真的完全的烂掉
它开始烂掉
那你看一下60分K
来我们回到60分K
60分K来到这个地方出现上限
现在是9点16分
代表隔壁这个60分K
其实还要好一段时间才会收
所以你其实可以不用急躁
那我跟你说
你就算等它市场这样子
再度上来的这里
再来做空都不止
真的你不需要空在最高点
你因为这个动作反而可以省略好多好多钱OK来我先回答几个同学的问题
这是一个阿耀的同学
他说他黄金买在9月14多单买在这个地方
在这里
等一下我们会去看黄金
跟22.05
在这个地方
22.05
然后买了当下有在想日K这么凶
是不是应该等这样子
然后又一整天没有出手
所以通常的经验他说
叠很凶出现小呼唤或是摸边界
可以顺利上去就没事
OK
然后他说
如果这种一路叠到底
很容易被停损
导致养出一棵圣诞树
发现原来是多方必死盘
给一些建议吗
来我给你一个
我先从底下这边给建议
要避免自己在一个边界
那个一直摸一直摸摸成一个
做多停损做多停损做多停损做多停损的这种圣诞数
一大堆交易记录要避免这个的好方法
你必须要有一个市场以外很明确的执行的纪律
例如这个边界你只能摸
例如说一次两次三次
我通常我不会只有一次的
就是两到三次
等于说你只给他
假设你一次亏200美金
你只给他三次
总共亏600美金的风险
这个几百美金
几十美金
根据你的部位
你自己去调整
你要给自己一个
一个这种很明确的这样子
甚至你可以给自己说
我早上只能亏多少
亏完了
今天早上就绑瘦
那你可不可以给自己设定一个
一整天我只能亏多少钱
我只能出手几次
出手的次数到了我也不能下
亏损的金额到了我也不能下
所以只要你有这个硬生生写在外面的规则
放在那边
只要你乖乖遵守
理论上你可能会连亏三次
但是就会收手了
你不至于要一路亏成圣诞书
对吧
不至于这样子
那你说老鱼如果这样喷出怎么办
没有办法
谁叫我们在前面可能自己偷摸乱摸
就把今天的额度给用掉了
那你必须要在市场图面的外面用这个很明确的规则把自己框住我讲的这套规则不是只有我在这边讲给大家听
在很多券商的自营部
你知道他们怎么控制交易员吗
他根本不在乎这个交易员用什么规则下单
用什么逻辑下单
反正你会赚钱就好
对吧
好
但是他会在乎的是什么
我不要你赔钱了以后
一直赔
对吗
他不要你一头热的这样子摘下去
所以在各大券商的自营部
他们是会限制这些trader
或是某一只城市的单日可亏损的余额
甚至他最大可动用的口述
这个都会被限制住
除非你证明你有能力
hold住这么大的口述
再继续往上
如果你一直亏
口述就降
再亏口述就降
再亏就把你踢出去
因为你承受不住
是这样子的
那这些规则跟他们用什么方法做交易
一点关系都没有
单纯跟你会不会去在乎券商的钱
在乎你老板的钱
把它当自己的来做
还是把它当游戏一样乱打
这个就是他们会观察的
那我们来看这两个点
我们把黄金直接就先叫出来一下
黄金
黄金黄金黄金在这边
黄金同学下的那个点是14号
我照一下
14号来来来同学下的点在这里
对在这个地方
所以他是看这个互换这个尖尖的对吧
如果你吃这边防守这里我觉得很OK
然后我要跟你讲一件事情
当市场出现这根之后
本来上不去的边界出现了一个明确从4326走到4334的这一根
你的吃单大概在这里
防守本来在这对不对
这根收定了以后
你要把你的防守从风险从这个地方拉到你的成本
一定要这么做
为什么要这么做
因为走出去的行情
如果他维持这个涨多跌少的东西他必须要在这个地方4330这附近他可以回来踩但是他不能再回来到你原来的位置所以你一定要这么做
所以你很有可能会在这个地方被不赔打掉
这个出手我觉得很OK
没有什么问题
这个出手不是你的问题
这个就是这样子而已
然后你说22.05的边界尖尖的
來22.05分
在這邊
這個你在這個地方摸大顆度
我再猜這個時候的60K應該是長這樣子
在這邊摸
我覺得沒有什麼問題
這個比較有經驗的同學應該知道這邊
慣性下不去下不去回來這附近摸
但是你的防守大概到这里
那也是一样的动作
行情这边还不用拉不赔
但是有这一根出现
这个这么明确的一大根
冲很远的K棒
它不应该一下子就没力
这句话请你记起来
请所有同学记起来
我们今天要讲的概念
就是这种一大根的K棒
它必须要有能力延续原来的动作
应该继续走的
该发生的要继续发生
那如果很用力的冲了很远
结果从头到尾被吃下来
哇
那这单往下破底的几率就变高
所以在这个时候
你还是要出现这根以后
还是要做一个什么
不赔的动作
那如果你是用更大的科度
假设你是吃60k的单子
那对60k来说
他还没有真的出去
那你就是承受你该要的风险
没有办法
好不好
这就是不同科度的逻辑
所以我觉得你一整天都没有出手
你出手在这两个地方
我觉得没有什么问题
这个阿耀同学
不用过度的去检讨自己的停损在哪里
也不用检讨什么
不用
这就只是两次失败了
好就这样
我不知道各位有没有这个经验
如果你有照着标准图
该要等待的东西做
其实常常都有机会
會讓你用不賠的角度離開市場
來我調查一下旁邊的同學
我的問句是這樣子
是不是你有照著圖做的
吃單以後其實常常都有機會拉不賠
至少用不会亏钱的角度来赌这个部位
对吧
后面会涨会跌
那是另外一回事
但是常常都会有一段
这段出去让你可以把风险
拿掉给他赌赌看的
有没有
这种就是你有等待的好处
我们现在再回来看
眼前的小纳黄金
小娜不要乱做空哦
因为这个样子这边
我觉得没有到很漂亮哦
来黄金呢
黄金来
推到60k
我刚刚是不是说60k它不漂亮
对不对
那现在老玉但是它长上去了
你就给它长
你就让60k上
60k下
我才找得到干干净净的那个边界
而且那个边界很有可能会是60k等级跟5分k等级
大概都在同样的边界
你现在就让他冲这边不好做
然后我们在做交易的时候
我其实很懦弱
我不是一个很勇敢的人
所以我喜欢等别人死光光了以后
我再踩在人家的尸体上面去测试他
很贱对不对
但是很賤的人往往活比較久
你知道嗎
在市場上是這樣子
那些很勇敢的勇者
通常都是第一個被抬出去的
好不好
市場就是戰場
我們不要站在第一線跟人家衝
不要
OK
好
再下一個
同學想要我聊一下
為什麼互換比標準圖還難練
你的标准图应该是指破底翻
其实互换跟破底翻
两个都是我在讲的标准图
一种是互换
一种是破底翻
那互换的确比较难拿捏
哪里难拿捏你知道吗
来我用
我用
这边要注意哦
这个边界开始出现这样子
这边还在中间对不对
你多等一下
多等一下
看一下15k
15k也还没有到很漂亮等等因为下面引线都还是一大堆等一下哦还没还没还没好的点在上面
但是现在这个位置
它底下都在涨下引线
有没有看到
它在涨下引线
忍耐一下
所以都还没有到很漂亮
也不是好空点哦
如果你说你在这个尖尖的隔壁这里
做空这里
你一空下去就吃了人家的墙壁
就撞到人家的墙壁
这不是一个好空点
不要不要
好不好
人还没有还没有
职场上被哥哥的人也可以活很久
好像是
那我要来聊一下这个
为什么互换比我讲的破底翻还难拿捏
因为很多互换会是像这样子
我用刚刚小黄金的就好了
这个正好有一个互换的概念
对不对
我们把后面先遮住
来看一下
大家看这边
这边你说它有没有支撑
有没有压力转支撑
有
但是同一时间
我也看到了
这边有上引线
这边有支撑被跌进来
所以压力转支撑的行李下
它有支撑
又有压力
所以这个会是一个问号的互换
它本来就没有很好做
那什么情形下的互换会是好做的呢
如果今天的互换是这样子
注意看我话
行情咻的走出去的
然后市场又咻的回来
而且大K棒不是真的长在互换这里
是长在中间
所以到后面留一段距离
让我们可以让市场去缓冲
像这样子
如果有事有这样子的
走出去又走回来这个边界
然后这个注意看这根
这根我放很大
这个停顿的边界他没有停在下面
没有停在边界以内
他停在边界的以上
然后这边有个小亚当满足
可以哦
那这个隔壁这个呼唤我喜欢
所以我这边收敛一下
我们先单纯讲呼唤
我不喜欢的呼唤是来到这边
直接就一个大的下来
这边可能有支撑有压力
这种呼唤我不喜欢我喜欢的呼唤我换个颜色好黄色好了我喜欢的互换是这样子上去稍微高了一点点
在上面有个整理然后叠下来
这里有一根比较明确的下沙的K棒
是跌破上面的边界
然后走一个小亚当的概念把它翻下来
所以行情来到这个地方
来到这个互换的边界
它出现下沙
但是有尖尖的长角的下影线
长在这里
这个的是我觉得好很多的
而且比较好判断
这样可以吗
那我不喜欢的
来我继续延伸
刚刚这样子的
这个下沙如果是这边长
我把这段放大的话
好不好
放大的话
上来整理
注意看哦
如果它是长上影线
上影線
上影線看我畫的
來到這個邊界
一大堆上影線來到這個邊界
你覺得我會說什麼
我是不是會說啊好兇哦
例如說這三個5分K都是常上影線
三個5分K濃縮一下就是一個大大下殺的15分K
哇這15分鐘做多的力量怎麼都沒有啊
買一下就被壓下來
哇 我不要 我不要
你看眼前的黄金
我刚刚是不是跟各位说这边行情没有很顺
潜力跟你差一点想要打我的脸
对 你说老玉 你说不要做多 结果又喷上去
但是你看 你们觉得这边行情咻咻咻咻咻
没有很好做 对不对
小娜
来喔 出现这个以后 反而我比较好去判断它
那出現這個以後
如果他收一個長長的下影線
收上去
哎呦
那是不是我要做空的想法又拿掉了
對不對
各位懂我的意思嗎
來
老玉小10k很漂亮啊
小10k這個邊界很漂亮啊
你在小10k的邊界剛剛這裡
如果你是這樣子決定
那就是剛剛的這裡啊
就是剛剛的這裡
就是這附近
大概就是這裡
那你說這一根的老魚
你剛剛不是說十字線這樣子你空在這邊太接近支撐了啊不好空后我眼前就被打脸了但是有关系吗我没有要照着不属于我原定计划的东西出手
所以一整天里面有九成
跟我想的都不一样
不一样就不一样
就给他给他
我要的只是跟我一样的那个10%的东西
好我就做这个
就这样就好了
我并不打算每一分每一秒都看得懂每一个行情
这个没有什么必要
而且现在美股开盘
你就等一下吧
开盘其实市场是很混乱的
好不好
嗯 这边
不要 我也还没有打算夹
我觉得太近了 等一下
好不好
来 还有嘞
这个是一个网友他写信给我
他说看了直播快六年
他是留言在那个老鱼那边
老鱼的FB
各位留言会我会收得到
只是因为留言比较多
我不见得会立刻有机会回
OK
所以我要的翻亚当却不翻才是重要
真的就是那个该发生却没发生
好不好
那今天我有说要跟大家聊结算日
对不对
我先跳出来聊一下结算日
我们来看日线的小纳
来
日线
我觉得这边图
用这个看好了
这个图比较大
日线的小纳
各位看一下
它长什么样子
我把它
边界在这对吧
在三天市场就要结算
那通常我的经验是
结算的时候会有大量的成交量
从前一个月份
跑到下一个月份的成交量
現在才剛開始
這個微型的小納的成交量
你說這裡最多到100萬口
它常態是100萬到200萬都很常見
所以才第一次進來
所以我可以剛開始觀察
我還不用很認真
大家的均價大概在這個地方
就這一整根全部都是大家的均價
這100萬口成交量
不管你買在高買在低
反正大家就在這裡
那今天也还是在这个范围内
那如果
接下来三天四天五天都在这里
那是不是累积出了好多成交量
大家都约略的成交在一个区间的附近
你知道这样子我反而很喜欢
因为它如果是成交在日线等级的这个区间的下缘
而且这也是周线的区间下缘
这个月份这是六月份的合约
六月份的合约在这边结算之后
难得出现一个盘整的样子
这其实是我们比较不常看到
在过去常看到的是
是结算的时候就一路涨
涨了两个月或跌了两个月
但是因为他难得看到盘整
反而我很喜欢
你知道为什么吗
这边是不是累积了大量的成交量跟均价各种东西在这边
6月份的人9月份的人现在两边的人都在这
所以如果来注意看
如果这边下不去
你在这附近建立多单的部位
这其实是一个相对好防守又好进攻的位置
假设行情这样子结算了以后跑到这边去
走到区间的上缘
你知道这边震荡一下
其实很容易往这边冲出去
那反过来说
如果最近的行情
区间在这边
这两天在这里
结果之后有一天是这样子跌下去
例如说这样子
这样子
跌破这个区间
这时候行情如果再度上来这个地方
的日线
其实是空方很值得观察的点
因为原来大家的平均成本在这边嘛
所以既然平均成本在这边
然后他行情是这样跌下来对不对
跌下来跌破平均成本
又回到这边的时候
来各位如果你是凹单亏钱
又回来到你的成本
你通常会做什么事
脚底抹油赶快跑
可以有让我可以落跑的机会
不赔钱就赶快离开
哇赶快离开
所以会有很多人
当初凹单的做多在这边的人
下来没有停损又回来到他的成本可能稍微凹一下一开始下跌就赶快跑所以赶快跑就容易促成这个地方出现这种尖尖的上影线
一旦出现这样子
很容易就再往这边走
这样
那我自己我是往做多的角度走
因为毕竟我眼前看到的是这样子
那我也还没有下大部位被打掉就算了
反正我就先试试看试试看
就是这种感觉这样子
好不好
看一下短線
短線 你說要做空嗎?現在這邊做空都不是很漂亮的喔
借我來到1K看一下 我要帶大家看
喔!這裡有一個 今天課程的主題
有一個我先講
現在跌不下去 對吧
所以我們不知道股市外來會不會漲
但是我們看得到現在
剛剛的這個1分K就是當時的現在
有沒有出現一個不該出現的東西
因為這邊跌下來有跌破一些
他應該是出現像這樣子的大K棒
繼續的往下殺才對
像這樣繼續殺
卻沒有對吧
那現在的1K來這個地方出現上影線
我就知道市場邊界在這邊
这里的确上不去,但是这里也突然下不去
K棒这么强势,先不要跟它作对
所以现在两边都有引线
那我就看,退一步看
我画一条边界在这附近
这个边界是谁比较常在用
刚刚是不是下不去
结果刚刚盘中开盘的时候
跌下去以后
涨破边界以后是不是又在这个地方400-405这边下不去
各种下不去
对吧
所以这就是市场引线在告诉你的事情
他刚刚在这个地方应该就要继续的维持
跌多
涨少
这里很关键哦
跌多
涨少
这个跌理论上应该要出现这样子
他应该跌多
前面从这边走到这边的这个距离
这段距离应该要从这边也走到这边
他应该要走下去该发生没发生换谁在绝望换做空在这里面的人要逃跑每一个成交量都是一个多单一个空单
对吧
这个我们讲很多遍了
所以做多的赚钱就是做空的赔钱
那做空的赔钱
当它涨上去的过程中
有一个人逃跑
两个人逃跑
现在就是做很多做空的
正在逃跑的时候
然后做多的人趁机在这个地方
在压力区域有成交量
做空的停损做多的出场
两个又是一起同步
眼前我看到的这边
做多我在抵抗
你说老爷那我在这里做多好不好
我再回来到这边我可不可以做多
来
可不可以做多
不能现在就在评估未来可不可以
我可以抓好边界
那我们可以预计说
如果边界出现什么样子
我们要做什么事
假设他待会从这边这样跌回来
跌回来到这个边界
出现了这一根
这个十字线
这个或是就像这个一样的
你在隔壁这边坐
很好防守
你就是守这个东西
这里的这条线
又是更多人用的线
所以不是只有你一个人孤军奋战
有人在用
那我就做
但是现在这一根这个下引线
我知道市场要冲
没错
但是
很强势的做多
没错
但是上面
这是对方的大本营
所以我就不喜欢做这件事
所以我们永远都在评估
例如说
当下
我知道当下弱了
你看我刚刚不是说
来到这边我不喜欢吗
这是容易被压下来的地方
那我们就不要做多在
尖尖的隔壁
所以收斂一下
尖尖的
我只会在区间的下缘
去观察尖尖的隔壁这件事
我不会在区间的上缘
这边有尖尖的这个
我不会理它
我不喜欢
因为它按下去就像刚刚这个一样
按下去就很容易撞城墙
要撞给别人撞
最好把它撞破OKOK
但是我不想撞
我是懦夫
我喜欢躲在人家后面
好不好那我们就可以规划说我要在这里等那下一步我要用几分k来等我要用五分k等吗
可以那我就在这五分k
其实五分k我可能就会拉下来一点点
五分k可能会等这里
这个我现在划线的地方
那一样就是等五分k回来到我的地方
出现这种
假设有这样子
下沙来到这里
要我的东西好隔壁吃
守这个地方好
那如果没有来勒
如果5分k就这样喷出勒
喷出勒就给他喷啊
就喷啊
反正我就不要啊
我每天进场我其实都在思考
也不是思考啦
我都在观察
哪边是适合我的
ok
来再来
回來講結算日
所以結算日的時候
這附近通常當周附近的盤中震盪都是很大的
最近其實各位應該都有感覺
你從日線來看就是一根這樣子的日線而已
但是盤中它的掃盪很大
各種消息飛來飛去
這通常都是結算日的慣性
結算在邊界這剛剛講過了
如果該月份走出趨勢很容易一路噴到結算
一路噴到结算这个之前其实大家都知道
那我特别跳出来讲一下台子期的结算
注意看喔
台湾的跟国外的不太一样
因为像美国是三个月
三个月一起
但是台湾的是每个月都有结算对吧
所以台湾常常出现在月底月初的这个时候
会容易噴一波
噴到我们每月第三个礼拜的礼拜三的台指期结算日
那附近容易出现盘整
你就直接记结论
月底月初如果有在边界出现尖尖的容易喷一波
喷到什么时候中下旬
因为第三周嘛
所以中下旬这时候
后半段容易出现剧烈的震荡跟盘整
这个东西请你记起来
但是我不敢保证每一个月都一模一样这么做
来这是7月份
7月份他在这个地方
来7月初是不是在这里
这是不是日线的比例
然後就一路走到這邊
中下旬,這邊是不是開始噴一波
這時候是七月份的結算
噴一波回來,然後就到下面
八月是不是在這
噴一波來到中下旬
有沒有整理沒有很好做
九月份目前看起來
整個九月份就是我們講的
他也不知道他要去哪裡
就是前面跟到現在
月初到現在才子期都還在這附近鬼混就上上下下
那就這樣子給他吧
因為都已經9月15號了
就這樣吧
那如果下一個月份
假設10月份
10月份9月底10月份來到這邊
然後你看到日線等級出現尖尖的朝上
那你可能可以在這一天
隔壁的這一天可能是台灣的夜盤
然後去買這裡的P
那反过来说如果哪一天是在底下这里
在这里4万4这个地方
假设跌跌跌跌走到这个地方出现尖尖的
在月底月出这附近出现各种这种迹象
然后你要做的话
在这一天很适合去买上面这边的C的call
就是在区间的下缘出现尖尖的
你就买对面区间上缘那个价格
你就认为会来吗
这样到的时候就出一流一
到的时候就出掉一半
留一半
这个我们已经讲很多年
所以请各位自己用刚刚讲的这个逻辑
回去自己找
验证一下我们讲的东西是不是真的
这讲很久了
我可能有十年
我一直在讲这个东西
台子旗在一万多点的时候
我就在讲这件事情
四万多点我还是在讲这件事
OK
来
1分K
这个做多的力量还在
要注意
没有真的完全的烂掉
好不好
来
我刚刚前面是不是在讲说
我们会观察现在是不是跌不下去
所以我们其实不需要知道
未来的股市会不会涨
很多人会问说老于例如说我刚不是讲那个MU吗或是MUU这种用MU这个股市这一周出现这样子
我带大家看一下
之前出现周线长这样子的时候
在这里
周线整理周线长这样子
然后后面出去
周线长这样子
后面出去
周线长长上引线这种震荡的样子
哇!我就知道了
后面就下来
周线长这样子就上去
那现在呢
目前看起来这周线还是下引线
除非接下来几天一路杀下来
哇!那就变成是下杀的周线
可能就要来碰800这边了
对吧
所以从这个角度来看
看到这样子尖尖的下引线
来
跌到这边昨天理论上是要下杀的K棒
有盘中其实很凶哦
但是昨天美股开盘后
直接就一路的拉上去
拉到现在这样子
这个边界就是我们讲的
来
跌不下去的迹象出现在应该继续跌
却没有继续跌的地方
应该往下
在这边
这里应该要往下蹦蹦翻下去的地方
却撑住而且还盘中就变成这样子
该发生没发生
甚至前面前面的时候其实有很多也是这样子
例如说
好来刚刚小那
这里29480这边
刚刚盘中是一个大K棒上去
那照道理讲是要延续这个涨多跌少
涨多要跌少对不对
但是结果从这边开盘后面这一段之后
它怎么样
它没有继续涨多反而怎么样
跌多了
所以你光从这边你就可以想象一下
这是1K
这几根K棒综合起来的5K长什么样
有没有
我们心中就会有个底
它就很容易下来
现在看得出来
邊界出現尖尖的上隱線這個力量有點弱調
看來往這邊走的機率又變高了
所以做多這裡要做多很不容易
因為它一按下去仍然是剛剛我們看的牆壁要撞就给别人去撞就一直都是在做这件事情
在多头涨多跌少还可以进场吗
是不是可以找到跌少的时候进场
哦好问题来
我来讲一个角度
叫做满足区的概念
借我用5分K
你说我可不可以找到下一个涨多叠少的地方
这边
这边是不是涨多叠少
涨多叠少
有下一个涨多叠少在这里
符合我们刚刚讲的
那我可不可以在这里进场
我们要去思考一件事情
是我们吃的这个位置
有没有可能是底下
位置在这里
有没有可能是人家前面已经从这边
花了一大段时间涨到这边
简单的说人家前面该赚的都赚的差不多了
这很有可能已经是行情的最末端
所以如果我要做
注意听哦
我喜欢做多债
跌多涨少
跌多涨多跌少的第一个地方
这样
我没有画得很清楚
我没有画在这个黄线上
算了
我喜欢坐在第一次转折的点
我不喜欢坐在涨多叠少
涨多叠少
涨多
我不喜欢坐在末端
甚至有可能是满足区
或是压力区的末端
这样可以吗
同学这个果汁同学的问题很棒
但是因为我现在没有图
如果可以的话
欢迎你把你觉得有问题的那个图
丢到老鱼的金融笔记的FB
那边可以贴图
我再去看
那可以的话
我再拿到之后的影片来讲解
好不好
那有些短线只长一点点出去
我会说很棒
有两种情形
第一个Peter帮我解答了
有一些同学
他在初期训练的时候
我会给他比较严谨的框架
因为我希望他们建立出一个比较完整
比较严谨的这个基本的动作
所以一开始会绑手绑脚
绑这个绑那个不能下不能下但是等到他过一段时间同学也证明给我看他甚至都已经可以出金了可以干嘛了他自己知道他自己在干嘛
那这时候我就不会管那么多
我就会让你开始自由发展
你爱打1分K OK
有些同学就打1分K打得很顺
虽然我平常都叫大家不用打1分K
但是就有些同学到后来他很习惯
OK去打去打
有些同学喜欢摸来摸去 OK啊
他的摸也算是有道理的摸
就我会让他过
而且他自己知道他什么时候乱掉要收手
那如果是这样他自己都有底的
那我就会给比较多的权限
那什么情况下我会把权限收回来
例如说在训练同学的过程中
他本来很OK
就突然间他怎么某一天打出来的单子
你在干嘛怎么一直摸
不是要停手嗎?你怎麼沒有停?
如果是這個時候
我就又會把那個框框給加回來
好!接下來10筆交易
你只能打乾乾淨淨的標準圖
中間有點偷摸的有點怎麼樣都不能做
然後他可能就很痛苦的綁手
這樣子大概大概是這樣子
那再來有些時候例如說
假设是这样子
假设这段行情是发生在我们美股交易的时间
就是我们的晚上
在他这个前面有一个很明确很完整
干干净净的整理平台
虽然他没有上很多
但是因为他发生在可能欧洲盘的时间
就是我们下午4点到6点这段时间里面
整理很久的平台
这个边界很漂亮
虽然只有上一点点
但是可以值得赌
就算他没有这样子很漂亮
但是值得赌
赌什么
赌这个边界
够平
累积的量能
累积要停损的人够多
我来赌看看
赌看看会不会这样子出去
这个赌哦
就算他没有
没有由上往下下来
同学有按的话
我也给过
因为是心里面的那个做多做空的天秤
不是有个评分吗
这个评分我会加分
因为它整理的够久
够平坦
这样可以理解这个想法
我看一下 3262 见汉买在20.5
来等一下我会开始来回答同学的问题
我会先从这边开始好不好
3262是因为我看到就先先讲一下
我打错吗
3062对不起 3062
健汉
买在20.5 守19.5 是不是 我看一下周线
这个周线 来来 各位同学
周线就是我们讲的 周线是大科度的下源
刚刚不是有几只股票叫出来
我说卡在周线的中间吗
这是可乘吗
我忘记了 大家自己回去看刚刚的那个影片
像这个就是在周线的下源
所以同學第一步你的選股我覺得很不錯
周線下圓 ok
再來
眼前的
日線
下來日線其實做多的力量
微微的出來還沒有到很認真的
因為他其實邊界
我不是很清楚他的邊界到底在幹嘛
因為他沒有真的破你知道嗎
要破不破要破不破有人買又沒人買
所以如果我吃
你说手19.5可以
那接下来这几天
假设你今天是吃1.10的部位
你今天是吃1.10的部位
假设接下来往下杀
还没到你的停损
但是出现这样子
这一根的之后
你其实可以把再吃个三等份
总共吃到4.10都可以
因为有这一根比较明确
通常它会带着比较多的成交量
通常
現在他還沒有破我還不知道
所以你可以先用小部位先摸一下試一下
OK 整體而言我覺得OK了
只要有這個出現有這個
比較明確的跌破邊界然後又收回來的這個
哇這個很棒
這樣
各位同學們果汁同學的問題旁邊
SR同學跟Peter同學都幫忙回答完了
大家请上去看一下大家在旁边的留言我跟各位说我们这里面我这样看这些很多大神不要开玩笑这些很多人都比我厉害
上次也有一个王先生
那个也是很厉害在旁边说就是他那个厉害
我记得我很开心
我觉得大家都比我厉害
这太棒了
现在的小娜
你知道吗
虽然有这个下影线
我知道它后面要往这边长的几率
其实变高了
我知道
但是就是
你要我在这个地方做多
我按不下去
你知道吗
因为它就是压着这里
所以这种单子我会
我会在旁边这样子看
就不理它
那这边还有同学问
问这个
好我都先截起来好不好
还有这个
上面什么
我健康 好吧 我先回答这几个这几个这边有看到的好不好
在哪里 在这里
1727 1727
中华化这个吗
你要问的是什么 可以观察了吗 我看一下
等一下喔
同學們第一個請看這個周線
請回答一下這個周線我是平常我喜歡的周線嗎
我剛剛前一個那個同學問的那個在周線的下緣
我覺得那個相對起來周線就漂亮
那這個的周線是我
大家辛苦了大家辛苦了的周線
有没有人听得懂我这个梗啊
这个梗应该在最近很红才对啊
大家应该都会回去朝圣那个内断啊
这周线我不喜欢哦
所以日线的这个边界这里虽然有尖尖的这里
但是它在没多久的地方都是这种上影线
一大堆上影线在我面前
各位引線就代表市場曾經往上撞
但是被對面拿大鐵錘把他敲下來
代表對面也有一個很厲害的人包含今天買上去了買到92但是對面這個人居然还继续把它卖下来所以代表有人一直在卖东西
我不知道是谁
反正他就是涨上来他就卖卖卖卖卖卖下来
涨上去就卖卖卖
所以我不是很喜欢
好不好
来看下一个
6182合金
来第一个6182同学问说60K吃在9月11104
60K9月11这里104这个位置
来我就选你看60K
9月
所以我再猜你应该是吃在这里
如果你是看60k吃在这个边界
我觉得OK啦
纯这样子看勉强接受
为什么会说勉强
因为你看哦
这个下影线
你说他要破边界吗
好像有
但是他才破多久
破一点点而已
好像一个TIG 两个TIG
这种我很难定义它是破边界
对吧
所谓破边界的概念是像这个样子
我把它反过来
像这个假设这个60K是这样子
超级明确的
跌下去拉回来
那如果是这样子
反而我可以比较明确的去观察这个60K的边界
就像这个一样
所以这个我觉得
有点
有點尷尬
那我們說過嘛
做60K單以前
我一定會往上看上一個刻度
那就看一下日線
如果我看一下日線
9月11
9月11是這一根
我們回來到你吃單的當下
被擋住了
這樣是這一根
你知道嗎
這裡我會很猶豫
因為它
我無法在我吃單以前
找到日线等级的标准图
这个边界
注意看喔
各位我把它遮住
请各位回答我这是9月11号吃單之前的邊界,上面斜斜下面平平的哇,這種邊界比較容易往哪裡跑?
哇,這個有沒有
對啊,所以我覺得沒有很愛勒
對,然後再看一下周線,我沒有很愛
這樣可以嗎?
這裡有個同學說
一直做對人有幫助的事情
哇!
我覺得這個同學有這樣子的心得
真是太棒了
那給這位CHENG
這應該是正吧?
應該是張正
我不知道
總之應該是正同學
恭喜你
那我觉得你继续维持你这种心态
那你说我真的是无条件对别人好吗
有些时候如果人家对我不仁
我不见得会对他很好
我通常会对别人好
就是我觉得那个气感受起来OK
所以我会比较愿意去帮人家
如果那个气我感觉起来
那个气怪怪的灼灼的
我的第一个动作是先离开
先远离我不打算帮他
我先自保
洁身自爱比较重要
这样
小娜现在完全动不了
小娜
不要动啦
来
应该有撑住的下影线
却没撑住这个往下破
破到我画的这个边界的这个几率很高
各位注意我这句话
我刚刚是不是说我不喜欢在这种地方
带着钢灰去撞墙
我不喜欢买在这种尖尖的地方
因为这个墙壁还在这
你看你看我不喜欢
对吧
那现在这根就很重要
理论上这根这样子下来的
代表后面往这里碰的几率高
但是来这边碰啊来了
目前看起来很凶的K棒
假设他待会是这样子斜斜的来碰
那我也不会很爱的
假设他待会是这样子
有点斜来碰这边
那后面往下再破底的几率又变高了
所以我又要退一步了
住在同一個屋簷下的子子超沒禮貌
都會影響到你
該怎麼辦
罵回去啊
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:20:00 起〕